[Music]
in little girl big-money news submitted
by way fou Wednesdays as a six-year-old
youtuber when 30 million followers
recently bought an eight million dollar
property that's just poor money manual
thank you how you gonna make it to 65
years old to retirement age and still
have money left over if you spent it all
when you were sick it's probably the
parents or maybe they have like a
hundred million what do you think her
YouTube channel is unboxing Ryan's toy
Ryan's little sister yeah it's probably
the little sister that's making that me
she a beauty guru okay yeah they are
they are there and I'm like I don't even
want you do makeup you don't want to
blend eyeshadow better than me that's
crazy
Wow amazing six-year-old unit yeah
so this six-year-old youtuber she's a
South Korean YouTube star her name is
Boram boo room she boo boo
oh she's reviewing toothpaste her thing
is so she has two YouTube channels one
of them is it unboxing like a toy
unboxing filming and then another one
she calls it a vlog Channel but it's
mainly like they do skits oh it's her
and these two guys which I'm not sure
what type of take us watch them before
little like stories like they act out
stories with a graphics on on screen and
stuff see but she could be like 15
because also who are these two guys
they're probably the content creators
like creating the skids and all that
stuff I don't like that that makes me
feel weary anglers that makes me feel
worried if it's not like her older
brothers yeah cousin drew some cousins
I'm assuming they're neighbors even yes
so they recently bought a 9.5 billion
korean wan which is 8 million u.s.
dollars building in Gangnam oh damn
that's like we're really here
yeah Korea is it a rental property I'd
like to rent out to people or is it like
a giant mansion house oh it's a giant
mansion house I don't think they have to
know how to be business savvy I think
they're like that new money our money
management because like you don't know
how odd the longevity yet I wouldn't
know it's either crazy didn't even have
that much at six she got no she can't
possibly fathom her brain can not even
account that belongs to her even
probably it's society family like her
family set up her own family company
it's probably not like what the states
wouldn't when they had those rules based
off the Macaulay Culkin's had me [ __ ]
up the finances yeah ya know cuz you did
think you were in it and all that stuff
yeah they didn't I mean people say that
it was started there like cuz I had
talked about his own hey [ __ ] and
they're like it was started in 1930s but
I'm like no no they're they revised that
law because like Macaulay Culkin got
[ __ ] over in the 90s a lot of childish
[ __ ] over in the 90s and when I was
doing like work on movies and
commercials and stuff when I was a kid
we like nowadays if you're under 12
years old you're immediately in the
Union if you're getting work as a child
because they want you to be protected
but back then there were just like
[ __ ] like we'll just overwork these
guys we don't go yeah like Shirley
Temple yeah yeah cheesy garlic juice
that movie Judy with her nice doll where
it's out yeah oh my god it's not John
I'm like wow they were like feeding her
speed pills and making her feet and
pills were her diet
that's crazy and she would like go do a
commercial for like a burger company and
they would like she'd be like just one
bike please let me just take one yeah
yeah yeah they always called her fat and
said I was watching a documentary about
her cuz they said she wasn't like cute
like she wasn't a cute kid like the way
Shirley Temple had like a Cabbage Patch
face they had to like make over G violin
that was her biggest insecurity with it
what did they just find a cute girl she
had that voice
oh wow when they desire you yeah I don't
know I'm available
what goodbye oh yeah 30 years too old
maybe Wow how old do you think I am
don't answer that 25 good answer damn
you always [ __ ] up baby that's why he's
married and don't matter so is it just
like her in the house with just the two
guys like what is who lives here how
often is she working these are all great
questions that you know how much she
makes a year oh she's up there though
she could [ __ ] by 30 million
subscribers yeah yeah yeah cuz one has
thirteen point six million the toy
review one and then the video all that
money's got to come from brand deals
because like they don't really get the
ad revenue anymore right I don't know
they might because I look at this so she
could have thirty million subscribers
but she probably has a hundred and
ninety eight million views per video
okay well you know what I wish one day
we could get subscribers like that so
y'all need to subscribe to JK news make
sure you hit that button because we're
trying to make it a thirty million you
know that I can't exert that baby we're
like half the people that watch your
videos or aren't subscribed yeah I
thought that was nuts
like I recently checked Milan I was like
whoa like people just use that the
suggestion box yeah like that's how I
find people if you constantly watch a
channel and just keep popping up their
video don't need to subscribe when you
hear stories like this do you ever go up
man we should open a review channel take
our reviews million dollar building
never because I just know how [ __ ]
hard of a kid he is and then for me to
like get him in the right mood set
everything up get his attention like
come on let's do this maybe you should
be Tiger's tantrum corner and
you're okay it's like something's out of
the tantrum he's livestream it you're
like he's getting to express his voice
okay kids will watch it because it'll be
their guilty pleasure like they want to
be a bad boy but then they're not
allowed to so now watch Tiger Beat what
do you want to do that your hundred
million views per video I don't want to
exploit him like that yeah cuz then you
have people talking [ __ ] about your kid
yeah that's for a ten million dollar
building yeah I don't really
if they talk [ __ ] who cares you can't
understand yeah so for this this
boudreaux girl this little girl her
parents back in 2017 this
non-governmental organization called
save the children receive tons of
complaints from citizens in South Korea
who worried about her they're just
hating because they're worried about the
clips negatively impacting the emotional
and ethical development of young viewers
because there were clips that showed her
stealing money from her father's wallet
but that's like skits doll right it's
just like I guess it gives idea exactly
it's giving like bad bad ideas to kids
that are watching this cuz another one
well unless they show the repercussions
like if she stole a dollar and then
likes payment oh not bad like if she was
like hey this is why you shouldn't steal
then it's a lesson yeah but I guess I
don't know exactly what the videos
entail because they took them down and
it led to the sole Family Court ordering
the parents to complete a counseling
course designed to prevent child abuse
oh my lord
yeah that's what makes me so scared to
like support these channels cuz I'm like
I don't know how many money hungry
parents are like forcing their kids to
do you know and it makes me really sad
that's all asking if you want to do you
want to join the money now steer in 2018
the highest-earning youtuber was 7 year
old Ryan
earned an estimated he getting like sued
right now or something there's like some
lawsuit or he has to pay a penalty
because they were doing brand deals
without fully disclosing or not a lot of
advertised to like a certain age group
because they can't discern between an
advertisement and like I didn't hear
that one yeah there's something like
there's something about he they he asked
him he earned an estimated twenty two
million dollars last year yeah you don't
want twenty two million dollars a year
but then at that point money just
becomes like funny yeah it's just
monopoly what I like about money with
it's funny no cuz then it's like you
don't you don't have limit like nothing
will ever be satisfying
you could buy airplane him yeah that's
never gonna be enough you free I love
Kelsey yeah you can well we all you can
buy is bills forever and you don't have
to worry about how you're gonna pay for
this yeah but y'all the richest people
are the most miserable this is like the
classic case of like before you happy
now I just hate bills to be paid yeah
but you still have time to change your
brain rich and sad than poor and sad
I've done the poor inside fair but you
know this girl's not gonna grow up to be
normal right I'm already depressed I'm
not trying to go make money to be
undepressed i'ma still stay depressed
but at least my bills are paid she was
already dead inside like she already
looks like I'm a robot hey hey but
that's a lot better than the North
Korean kids the North Korean yeah have
you seen the North Korean guitar group
I'm happy yeah I promise yeah too young
let her be a kid that girls I mean her
channel up from what I like the very
little that I saw it does look like
she's just being a kid she could be like
an Olsen twin and then she's like
running her own fashion company at like
eighteen and stuff into man though I
think they'd be kind of like went behind
the scenes aren't they kind of weird
yeah one man Laird one hand like that
you know the traitor and one is like
dating a fifty year old now that
yeah who came out great uh JT Justin
Timberlake maybe yeah I think that's
Mickey Mouse crew that's probably the
only Ryan Gosling oh yes Natalie Portman
loved her but she took a break from
while I would for a minute right to go
to Harvard to count her money probably
do y'all think like Jojo C was gonna be
okay really the girl with the bow with
the pony oh and Frank and [ __ ] yeah I
just heard Frank and I knew what he
meant some of the buzz they get and
we're from Holocaust - yeah yeah -
golden retriever on a rainbow I know you
gotta know who she is a little girl with
like blonde but she's not really on the
side is her panting out a Hometown
Buffet somewhere do you have a hometown
because merchants like Claire's stores
and all cuz she's on Dance Moms
I thought she was part of like the
Norman Rockwell paintings you know
Hometown Buffet has the Norman Rockwell
paintings like that era I never know
she's now she's a child
oh she's like right now like doing
closet Shane Dawson and like she's there
she's in the youtubes yeah Internet's
too slow for me to put yeah I thought it
was like this old she's a walking pencil
case by I don't be gay all right she's a
walking junior high school kids folder
the binder that's what she's just thick
with Lisa Frank that was good
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]